I'm going to start with I've seen the
first six episodes of season two my
complaint is I have not seen seven
through ten
um and uh that you know that's the main
thing but
um I don't want to do spoilers but Jess
I'm going to start with you uh what can
you tease about your character's
relationship with uh Spock in season two
um it gets a whole lot more complicated
let's say that much
yeah I think that's pretty accurate I'm
gonna I'm gonna say that for for both of
you uh season two is ten episodes uh do
you have a favorite of the ten episodes
and why I'm gonna say eight and nine and
I can't say why because that would be a
spoiler
I would say eight
but I can't tell you why either
I just spoke to Anson and he said it's
eight now nine it's eight now nine
hey
is eight now nine has it been
oh I I see what you're saying yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right who knows who knows
let's
yeah Anson told me that he rehearsed on
the weekends for episode nine but would
not tell me why so I know that that's
obviously a big episode yes okay so nine
is probably my favorite then
so I'm so curious now you know
um one of the things though do you guys
look forward what do you prefer do you
prefer filming action or do you prefer
delivering and having to learn the Star
Trek jargon that you have to say in
certain episodes I think that the
variety is what we love oh that's what I
love
um that's the thing that's really
special about this show is that
we do a different genre every episode
and as a as a performer like that is a
total gift and like like a boot camp
every week you know like
um it never gets it never gets uh stale
or we can never be complacent so I love
both I see the nodding I'll move on to
something else one of the I think
episodes yeah one of this season's
episode uh episode seven I believe is
your Crossover with lower decks and for
both of you uh I obviously haven't seen
it yet but when you were told this was
happening were you like get the F out of
here how is this going to work I mean I
was definitely like curious about how
they were gonna do it
um but so pumped to get to like work
with them that's so great so exciting I
was gonna say you you're a little
talkative for me no yeah no I I didn't
realize you had turned to me uh uh
it was fantastic it was really yeah I
didn't hear you saying my name or
anything oh yeah that's fantastic it was
fantastic working with Tony and Jack and
you know it was really it was really
something the brother they brought up an
amazing energy uh to the episode so we
loved it I loved it
I'm totally teasing that's my fault for
not saying names
um so one of the things one of the
things that and this is for both of you
but one of the things I love about the
show is that it's like episode of the
week but it does seem like it's maybe
teasing towards like a Gorn War type
thing uh for each of you what are you
allowed to say not a lot There Will Be
Blood lots of blood okay
it does right exactly um Hey listen I
already have to stop I'm just gonna say
and I really mean it I really enjoy both
of your work tremendously on the show
and um you know congrats on a great
season and thank you for your time
thanks so much Steve thank you